r kelly a été condamné à 30 ans de
prison voici pourquoi selon le tribunal
fédéral de brooklyn le chanteur
américain organisée entre 1994 et 2018
un système d'exploitation sexuelle de
jeunes notamment d'adolescentes six
femmes étaient les principales
accusatrices même si le nombre de
victimes était plus élevé elles
décrivent avoir été violée séquestrée
drogué forcé d'avorter contaminés par
une mst le chanteur contacter ses
victimes grâce à la complicité d'une
partie de son entourage qui glissait un
petit papier avec les coordonnées du
chanteur après des concerts pour rappel
r kelly a vendu des dizaines de millions
d'albums principalement dans les années
90 et 2000 le chanteur de 55 ans fera
appel de sa condamnation a assuré son
avocate